hey everyone
welcome to simply loans youtube channel
in this session
we will be discussing about programming
versus coding
but before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies
so if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
trends then consider getting subscribed
to our youtube channel
and don't forget to hit that bell icon
so that you can never miss an update
from simplylearn
now without further ado let's get
started with the agenda for today's
discussion
so we have one point agenda today that
is programming versus coding
now both these terms are used as
synonyms to one another
if you search google you'll find the
same when you search for the definition
of programming
you can find computer programming is the
process of designing
and building an executable computer
program to accomplish
a specific computing result or to
perform a specific task
surprisingly when you search for coding
definition you'll end up finding a
similar
definition computer programming or
coding is a process of designing
and building executable computer program
to accomplish
specific computing result or to perform
a specific task
and it is also said that the terms
programming and coding
can be used as a synonym to each other
yet
there is one thin line of difference
between the book that's exactly
what we are going to discuss in this
particular session
so when you consider programming then it
can be
said as passing instructions to your
computing device
so what do you mean by passing
instructions anyway
okay to understand the definition let us
go through a small analogy
let us consider that we have a small
robot
now programming is something where you
tell your robot
to do something right here you can
consider
that you are telling your robot to
perform the operation of
a chatbot where you can tell your robot
to
search your mails and respond to it
right this is one analogy where you can
consider
the programming concept and again
another example is
telling your robot to perform some
mechanical operations
where it tries to fix your machinery
okay it is the same robot but it is
performing
in a different way or it is behaving in
a different way it is based on the
program you write or
the program or the instruction you give
it right so it is what
programming means let us go through
another example
where you tell your robot to perform
some machine learning operations
where it learns new things and behaves
according to them
so this is the term programming now when
you get into coding you can consider
coding
as an act of designing and developing a
computer device
to perform exactly as per the task it
has been assigned to
right how and what made the robot
to follow all your instructions right it
is one coder
who wrote all the gibberish code inside
its brain
to perform the task whatever you are
giving to it right
that process is called as coding so it
was the coder which
had written all the gibberish code
inside the brain of the robot
to perform the task whatever the user
has provided it so this is exactly what
the thinnest line of difference between
programming and coding
is programming is something where you
pass instructions to your computing
device and ask it to perform some tasks
and coding is something where you design
the computing device
or tell the computing device or make the
computer device
to be capable enough to perform the task
whichever the user is providing them
so with that we have come to an end of
this tutorial where we have discussed
the differences between programming
and coding i hope it was informative and
interesting
if you feel that we have missed out
something important or if you have
something important to discuss with us
or if you have any queries regarding the
session
then please feel free to let us know in
the comment sections below and we'll be
happy to hear it from you and
our team of experts will be happy to
resolve all your queries
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here